le bilan de l'opération d'ouvéa qui a
fait je vous le rappelle dix sept morts
six blessés 15 arrestations suscite
quelques réserves dans la classe
politique
je vous propose d'écouter trois
réactions collecter tout à l'heure par
bernard pradines haut il est clair
maintenant que monsieur chirac et les
siens pratiquer une politique de coups
de théâtre et essaye de peser sur les
émotions collectives des français en ce
qui concerne l'opération militaire en
nouvelle calédonie qui est concomitante
et qui intervient également trois jours
avant le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
elle a abouti à la libération des
gendarmes et du magistrat c'était un
impératif absolu mais elle se termine
par 17 morts j'approuve le gouvernement
d'avoir pris cette méthode est d'avoir
fait fait obtenir force à la lourde
je crois que il y a des moments où le
gouvernement doit faire face ces doit
faire front et faire respecter
l'autorité de la loi et de l'état le
gouvernement français s'est livré ce
matin un acte purement coloniale
c'est la politique de la canonnière et
ce qui s'est passé ce matin ne grandit
pas le lit majeur 23 gendarmes ont été
libérés mais au prix de la mort de
quinze canal
on ne peut pas considérer cela comme un
succès et cela fait surtout la
démonstration que la vie des mélanésiens
n'a décidément pas le même prix que
celle d'un blanc en nouvelle calédonie
voix